enjoying the Great Outdoors at Red Rock
Canyon will soon cost more the Bureau of
Land Management increasing the rates
beginning next year for vehicles
bicycles and even the annual pass well
today visitors are voicing their
concerns about the cost and the BLM
telling us what the funds will be used
for
it's just Majestic for me Beauty Bacco
is visiting her friend Tanya from New
York as an outdoor Enthusiast Red Rock
Canyon was a must for her but these two
friends were taken back from the 15
entrance fee which is about to go up you
do expect to go on a hike for free like
it seems a little bit odd that we'd have
to pay so much for to come to enjoy
nature the Bureau of Land Management
announcing fees will go up next year for
the Red Rock Canyon National
Conservation Area bumping up costs for
vehicles bicycles and campsites the
annual pass will also go up from thirty
dollars to 50 bucks
the increase according to the BLM allows
staff to continue meeting the needs of
the public while maintaining facilities
Trails infrastructure and future
improvements I think it's fair good to
keep it because if there weren't no
visitor center like this spot people
will get lost just enjoy the scenery
Stephen Bodie and his wife are new to
the valley and claim the increase is
still cheaper than going out to dinner
or other activities in Las Vegas we have
a lifetime senior pass
from the National Park Service
and that allows us to come here just
paying the reservation fee of two
dollars I just have to cut out my coffee
like
to go lesson lesson other things that I
can make at home so don't
drop of coffee for me to hike or you
know so I think it's it's more of a
priority thing
it's all about priorities all right not
everything is going up the BLM says fees
will not increase for pedestrians and
motorcycles